hello and welcome to this video playing
hockey I don't even know what he does
because you feel I've always got to
always got like but I don't I placed on
v6 at least two I'm true to what it does
i probably takes this right okay didn't
take on your three so we will maybe
transpose to some queen's indian
position i don't notice this line all
that well then it looks a little bit a
little bit awkward
yeah it looks awkward to put his to
blunder stuff okay let's take it that
was one of the ideas of queenie three
97 so move came and now I probably just
centralized
maybe queen b5 in minikin I don't know
but it's generally speaking them it is
just an exchange so
look at the eight maybe my bishop is
hanging always so it's not so easy to
take on c5 he's got this pin down still
somewhat Oh some of the knowingness pin
and now I can take probably technically
easiest we should be 202 701
pretty much falls apart now this is game
59 against him I've got plus 26
like resigned
yeah just stumbled into 95 huh
pretty pretty clearly yeah here there's
nothing much going all this is some in
an equal position I was thinking you
know what doesn't work
I was thinking about this but if form
this is actually a possible line
computer gives this and then the retreat
it's funny it's equal guarantor just
learn those memos and there's not much
to analyze really it's a I mean this is
motif whenever the Queen is this age
seven square there are often times which
is like that when there is a few K 1 G 2
so whenever the Queen looks at this pawn
and he has to be a bit careful somehow
um yeah he wasn't yeah thanks for
watching